confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs c'est le nom
du nouveau rendez vous que vous autres
la première salut c'est jimmy et je suis
ravi de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle
édition
on partira aujourd'hui en italie à la
rencontre de ludovic parti il a été
danseur professionnel il est maître de
ballet y vit en italie depuis plus d'une
trentaine d'années on va essayer de
comprendre son quotidien en plein
confinement et surtout comprendre les
raisons qui l'ont amené à partir et ce
qu'il fait aussi loin de là marty s'est
tout de suite
[Musique]
bonjour les deux vies deux parties et
merci de nous accueillir chez vous en
italie vous êtes dans quelle ville
exactement d alchimie chino vous y vivez
depuis combien de temps déjà agité
depuis cinq ans en fait j'ai vécue à
rome
je suis de nouveau sa fin tout est de
combien d'années passées en italie en
italie ça fait trente vous êtes maître
de ballet en italie alors c'est bien
cette émission parce que ça nous permet
de partir aussi à la rencontre de
martiniquais d'antioquia n'est qu'ils
font des choses extraordinaires ailleurs
que chez eux
maître de ballet vous travaillez avec
des dons internationaux et de tout
horizon et vous avez vous même été
danseur professionnel
oui c'est un professionnel
voilà donc maintenant je m'occupe et
danseurs alors tout à l'heure je vous
demanderai de forcément nous dire
quelques mots en italien ben oui c'est
on est tellement belle qu'on ne peut pas
s'en priver
on va essayer de comprendre un petit peu
avant comment vous vivez ce confinement
en italie c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
entendu parler ça a été un des foyers
les plus touchés en europe sinon le plus
touché avec beaucoup de cas de kovy 19
comment est ce que vous le vivez vous
dans votre ville et plus globalement en
italie on a vu quelques images mais on
aimerait avoir votre impression et votre
retour à vous qui êtes au coeur même de
l'italie
ok moi je vis dans une petite ville
d'encaisser leurs seins denses atteint
donc aussi aussi loin aussi des foyers
soyez qui les relance en tournant pays
donc en martyr les dessine surtout
environnements intelligents donc à 550 m
ici est donc l'un d'eux dit les gens
passaient pour l'acquittement tranquille
donc je sens très peu je sens je te
promets course a vraiment d'ailleurs les
gens sont c'est là qu'il ya une
impression assez particulière les gens
ne parlent pas entre ces quatre serres
cd&v sur son téléphone connecté et donc
voilà donc ça c'est ça de silence à ses
deux ans quand même mais sinon je trouve
que les gens ici là pendant ma vie c'est
francky quand même la danse et est une
discipline très exigeante qui demande de
l'entraînement régulier quotidien
comment est ce que vous arrivez à gérer
ce confinement avec vos élèves qui sont
des professionnels de grands danseurs
comment est ce que vous arrivez si vous
arrivez d'ailleurs à trouver une
solution pour continuer à les entraîner
écoutez j'ai travaillé ces deux
dernières années
gagné 1,21 et donc avec une en sorte que
tout le monde entier est en fait je leur
ai proposé de l'ordre les cours parce
qu'eux aussi sont confinés et trois
semaines déjà et j'aurais proposé de
redonner courant comme de continuer de
coucy et devant monaco un cours
quotidiens dont cuba parce que je mets
dans sa formation classique compagnies
classiques en fait donc je leur donne
une barde donc assez calmes à quelques
exercices au milieu on appelle 2200 pas
donc ça doit vraiment peu de tenir en
soirée je les encourage aussi à prendre
retrouver cours parce qu'il ya aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de collègues dans le
monde entier dans les cours oscillent
dans ce sens m comment je le sais je les
encourage donc faire prendre des cours
avec d'autres hommes d'autres ont fait
ça et à maintenir aussi le moral c'est
très difficile pour eux parce que ils
sont assez jeunes ils ont entre 18 et 25
ans et la part d'autres responsables de
leur famille de leur pays dans cinq
usines d'italie du japon du canada de
chine taïwan partout donc ils sont dans
un pays dont ils nous parlent pas la
langue parce qu'il ya à prendre et
profilé tout cela parle tout seul dans
un appartement et ce n'est pas aider nos
mots que j'ai senti un fait
le besoin de les soutenir un petit peu
et d'autre qu'être solidaires avec eux
et de les laisser dans nos quotidiens de
leur proposer une classe donc avoir
rendez-vous au quotidien comme ça pour
rien que leur journée à mort - activité
on tuait les choix quelques mots en
italien avant de se quitter
quant à john forzani ti kréol saleh se
serait jamais être pas maudit respecter
les règlements et c'est un mur merci
beaucoup lui dovi deux parties depuis
l'italie on était ravi d'échanger avec
vous on souhaite beaucoup de courage et
surtout de la prudence bien évidemment
et on espère se revoir très bientôt en
martinique maxi cd jenny et j'étais ravi
de vous accompagner on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle destination
[Musique]